et oui je le redis voyez une vérité non
mais une affirmation dit même avec une
voix forte n'est pas une vérité excusez
moi voilà c'est mon déterminisme
culturel peut-être je le redis je pense
que vous arrêter au milieu du gué et je
pense que c'est ça qui fait que ça peut
poser problème est que ce discours là
peut être pris politiquement et nous
mettre face à une situation politique
difficile
vous dites moi je ne dis pas que nous
sommes tous égaux par exemple vous
prenez 25 enfants il y en a qui
apprendront plus rapidement les
mathématiques plus rapidement le
français etc ça certes mais vous vous
dites à un moment ne vous arrêtez à
lavit ya indéterminée
il ya une question génétique mais vous
ne dites pas qu'il ya aussi des aspects
sociaux et culturels
mais oui mais vous dites pas le
contraire mais vous ne le dites pas donc
ça peut aller c'est à l'interprétation
en plus vous êtes un scientifique et
vous courrez un plateau télévision dont
je dirais que ce schéma la pensée
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce que vous
dites tout cas c'est pas les codes vous
êtes dans un schéma de pensée dominant
ultra dominant et vous le savez est
d'ailleurs pour justement le dire vous
dites on vient casser les codes mais
tous les jours les plateaux de
télévision sont en veille personnes qui
ont votre courant de passer et qui
disent on casse les codes et je dis que
nous sommes face à une difficulté c'est
que si nous ne disons pas qu'il ya aussi
les schémas culturels et sociaux pour
rééquilibrer les inégalités
alors alors nous sommes face à un
problème qui est extrêmement politique
et je vois mais comme vous ne le dit pas
et vous laisser à penser
non ce n'est pas un procès d'intention
je vais au bout au bout du débat
politique avec vous peut-être que ces
voix là bon ben vous voyez comme les
choses sont dites bon mais nommée très
bien que c'est que ça ça va au bout
d'une controverse mais je pense que
c'est utile que l'on et je vous le redis
madame la présidente je pense que quand
on invite monsieur alexandre qui est une
personnalité connue et reconnue
je dis qu'il faut un plateau qui
d'équivalence pour aussi porter la
contradiction